so you
[Music]
can perfect
[Music]
yo
what's up guys it's been a long time
since i just been right here me you and
marty it's it's been a while guys what's
up i am thomas dopeziolo whatever you
want to call me this is marty o'neil
drastic graphics what's up folks how are
you feeling today oh i'm so excited to
be let's go
yes guys this is the first solo episode
in seven to eight weeks
so guys we're trying this new thing to
like it's called getting paid by youtube
so we're trying not to
discuss crazy things right off the bat
all right we're just gonna ease into it
we're gonna chill we're trying our best
we're not a good non-age restricted run
right now we are we are
[ __ ] pumbled yeah right there too
yeah sorry yeah that's impossible i
can't do this i know i know but
we got we just
we're trying we're trying though we're
trying our best i'm doing i did a video
last week with no cussing or smoking and
i'm shocked i didn't cuss in any of the
outtakes or anything hmm something like
dope was yellow video yeah i did like 12
minutes without cussing that's insane
all right my jeans inside were like
say something
um
so yeah here we are here we are guys
it's been a while i just wanted to start
off by saying hi
thank you shout out to every single
person that has been hanging out with us
just supporting watching chilling thank
you guys marty and i really appreciate
it guys
and let's get straight into this episode
okay
this episode is going to be a catch-up
because we haven't seen you guys in so
long and the last time we talked about
something
we had to cut it off because we went oh
let's not talk about it that's today
we're talking about that today all right
this episode's about
triumphs and tribulations is what marty
wanted to go for all right what's what's
been the wins what's been the losses
because you know here
on social media on earth people just
like to show you their wins all right
they like to show you only the cool
stuff and look at my new car they don't
like to show you all the [ __ ] that
went into it all the work that went into
it and sometimes losses people don't
like to admit to losses for i lose [ __ ]
all the time i don't win situations all
the time but i will win in the end
so that's why i don't care
here we go let's get into the first
thing i want to talk about
we want to talk about the latest stretch
of guests that we've had okay
i couldn't even tell you how long ago it
was marty but the la the first guest we
had this long string of run
uh was goblin you guys have asked for
goblins ev this in the comments of the
goblin video you asked for when's the
next goblin episode i get it nick is
super good at storytelling i i get lost
in his stories that's why
i watch him he's i'm a fan of his so
straight off the bat guys thank you so
much that was our first introduction to
miller lite also that was our first
perfect way to kick that [ __ ] off all
right so thank you guys for making that
first like impression to miller light
was like who how good job hell yeah yeah
they were stoked all right
so thank you guys so much goblin we'll
be back but we're trying not to like
drown you guys out i don't want to just
keep repeating guests back to back even
though he does great i love the
conversation not everybody wants to see
the same guess all the time so we'll
space it out he'll be back eventually
but uh next guest after that was right
after that was adam adamil i loved the
episode all right for everyone out there
that hasn't seen it the adam ill episode
was very uh
uh it's like a rare moment that i get to
talk to somebody else that's been
through the same exact things i've been
going through for a decade
he has been in the community step by
step every event what's up every comes
any event on that he's at we're doing
the same stuff except he's the host so
it was such a good
background i didn't know adam wasn't
doing all that crazy [ __ ] as a young kid
dude
i had no idea i know that dude like i
know him well so
that was awesome uh the rapper beef was
a little i didn't
i didn't know what i was doing with that
one i didn't realize it was gonna go so
dark you didn't realize you were walking
through a landmine field of [ __ ] i
didn't know guys i'm very sorry but that
was a great episode if you haven't
watched it you have three hours of fun
ahead of you all right it was over three
hour episode that was a fan favorite
amongst all the monsters did that post
yesterday
big time dude adam was
he's just great talking camera that's
what he does for a living so
it translates you know so uh we had
goblin adam and right after that was
trevor wallace trevor wallace super
funny dude
like i said on the show as soon as we
heard uh that his name popped up on our
booking agent
100 no questions asked get him on here
he's a fun this is a different realm for
him i could see i was like
oh
i might get you too [ __ ] up if you
start smoking with us so that's why we
didn't smoke and he told me later he's
like no i'll smoke at home
so that's how that went i gave him some
some joints but he's on tour so everyone
out there right now trevor wallace is on
tour right now trevor wallace comedy.com
i believe it was go check him out guys
i've been keeping up with his instagram
marty he's selling out theaters oh yeah
the eaters that's inspired cool man just
to watch him off his little his clips
and his little bits and the sketches and
[ __ ] take it this far yeah
that shows inspiring
anybody willing to go up and go hey
and start
like hey judge me like that's like you
know you're brave you're brave and you
love it that's the only way you can do
it
uh so yeah go check that out trevor
wallace was a great episode right after
that is one of my favorite episodes okay
the dr drew episode was awesome i
thought it was great
it was one of my favorite talks i've
never spoken to a doctor before just a
golden valley medical
welfare section 8 health care center
from merced that's the only place i've
ever been i've never talked to a doctor
that went
oh you're successful no you know what
you're doing like all my doctor's like
yo i got my degree
that's the doctors i've been to so um
he was awesome for some reason it didn't
perform as well on youtube as i thought
it was going to do i thought it was
going to be like the one of the biggest
viewed videos just based off of how
great that man speaks and
what a great update
what happened so i [ __ ] loved it but
anyway anyway if you haven't seen it go
watch the doctor true episode it was
very informative like
i learned [ __ ]
i loved about that that it just shows
that we could take like the whole other
approach the other end of the spectrum
than we normally do is on the terms of
like
drugs smoking then yeah the normal
like
conversation we have this was the whole
other side of it and yeah it just showed
how versatile the show is everybody can
come and have fun like you don't have to
be just i get high i should go the show
like no your financial advisor you don't
even get high come on the show yeah are
you interesting that's our thing like
are you interesting
yeah we'll make we'll be the judge of
that is this [ __ ] interesting
enough for us to go all right let's set
the day up let's have him come in
or her it doesn't matter i'm saying like
we we really
research our guests before we say yes
for sure that's all but dr drew super
hyped couple mind blown moments in that
episode too like just actually learning
important [ __ ] yeah
dude he taught me more than i've ever
learned in a health class
in one hour yeah damn our education
system is trash so um dr drew episode go
watch it i thought it was unreal super
good
the next person right after that oh that
was right after the atom22 from no
jumper
guys
the i was on no jumper yesterday all
right i went and did a guest spot on no
jumper comes out next week
the one thing he brought up during the
interview and he was interviewing me was
hey man i like uh you know i went
through some of the comments on
your guys's youtube channel on my i was
just looking for sarcasm [ __ ] he's
like i'm just looking for the fun stuff
and he has almost not
99 of every comment he's like i read on
that was positive
and he's like i've never seen that
online i go i know man our fans are a
whole different crowd of people hey
you're an [ __ ]
smoke your wheat over there you don't
have to be over you don't have to chill
with us get the [ __ ] out of here so um
that was very awesome i thought that was
cool that he actually brought up like i
went through it and dude no one's a dick
and the same thing with adam adam text
me the next day he goes bro
nobody like when he said he went on his
twitch live oh adam ill 1922. adam ill
went on his twitch and said
we went to go search for [ __ ]
comments and i didn't find it i know i
didn't erase any either it's just
i left it unless someone's being like a
racist horrible person i won't erase
your comment if you don't like it you
can say that um the comments are very
well thought out meaningful that's it
makes our jobs a lot easier trying to
make things happen
like we always say the fans are what we
pitch how awesome they are that's it i
mean dude even franklin was like what
i'll get on to that adam 22 was just
like astonished that it was so good but
anyway
great interview a lot of the comments
were i've never seen the side of adam
before i'm like yeah he doesn't get
interviewed often i want to know more
about this person
and a lot a lot of people go how are you
a fan of no jumper you don't even know
where he's from you guys have to
remember
if i just didn't ask the questions that
i already knew would be a pretty short
interview
i got to ask adam mill where did you
grow up man for the audience they need
to know and i can just go hey adam hill
i know where you're from
moving on like well what
terrible interview that's like being on
the inside joke and the camera is not in
on it like yeah no you're framing you're
pointing them to give to let the
audience know i'm trying to build a
story yeah i'm trying to build like
i'm just trying so that's why with
atom22 just started opening up a little
more a little more a little more a
little more i just i thought it was a
great episode go watch the atom22
episode
right after that all right all right
this is a catch-up episode right after
that
was the franklin from gta episode sean
fontino guys
i've been on
streaming i've live stream i brought
people brought up grand theft auto i'm
like yeah uh sean sully's a cool guy
you know how many people don't believe
my stories man like a lot of people
think i'm just talking about random
shit's like yo you've never been out of
the house never been chased by the cops
all right good for you good for you
but
is it really unbelievable that little 14
year old me selling sacks are you
serious like i know a lot of 14 year
olds not anymore but
i knew a lot of 14 year old kids selling
meth and coke and like you know it's
earth
um
so when i brought up the solo thing
people like yeah [ __ ] right you met
franklin from g like all right bro
if i'm gonna make some [ __ ] up i'll
write a [ __ ] non i'll write a [ __ ]
sci-fi book
yeah everything we ever talk about in
here why would i
my biggest like
fallback would be like i lied
ew and then was caught oh no no thank
you that'll never [ __ ] happen to me
because i will just tell the truth
enough crazy [ __ ] happens yeah enough
crazy things happen for me to go no no
some wild [ __ ] happened
so uh
that's why i love bringing him in i'm
like no he's a real person
you guys thought it was like
he is on instagram bro
so
franklin from grand theft auto i'm gonna
say best episode yet that's why from
like as a fan watching our stuff
that was the best episode we have done
on this channel i thought to me
i was so
lost in this man's story just listening
like whoa
and i'm imagining it like when he's like
every time you get out of the car you
say
yeah
it was like watching training day for
the first time all over again oh damn
like
the thing is like when i see that i'm
like
do you guys think that people are lying
fools have automatic machine guns like
third world countries to guard fools
walking in houses all and when he said
i'm like
oh you were real you guys were about it
and he's talking about the story he told
a story about his older brother was in
prison with some dude that said he out
tried to kill your brother a few times
blah blah i found it wasn't him but
like look at that things happen every
day for nothing just mistaken identity
come on man jesus christ yeah but anyway
if you guys want to have a great time
two hours of just
an amazing storyteller all right sean
solo franklin a great storyteller we
will 100 have him back can't wait to
read that book um
that brings us up all right that's the
last
all those guests and then the solo was
here all i guess here we are today
what time are we at like let's say 14
somewhere around there yeah yeah okay
i felt like a long time yeah yeah it
felt like a long time
um
so yeah that's what's been going on guys
thank you so much for being here all
right real quick just thank you again it
just feels so awe that we haven't been
here so long
it's weird to me all right it's weird
but it's like a in a good way so here we
go guys i'm gonna light this
[ __ ] up let's go this
demonetization kush
whatever you want to call it
demonetized og
here we go all right
let's start here we go
this is going to be the tribe and
tribulations the wins and losses the
pros and cons of life episode
so let's start off with the
[ __ ] triumph start off with the
win marty are you ready tell everybody
what you did last the past two weeks go
we won't go into the bad [ __ ] yet uh-huh
we'll only stick to the good good good
stuff didn't you see my notes
yeah yeah oh okay i gotta
take it yeah
man it's been a [ __ ] rollercoaster of
past of a past month for real oh oh yeah
yeah we're we're really going to get
into it but yeah getting into the
triumphs first first we're talking about
another two super bowl commercials yeah
i didn't realize this was gonna be a
recurring thing right last year marty
filled two bowl commercials this year
they were back to they played them back
to back mm-hmm i was like miley cyrus
like
this is marty's [ __ ] yeah go for it so
yeah that involves when you when you
film on these kind of productions that
involves it's like it's damn near like a
gta mission because you don't know where
you're going to be or who you're working
with up until like the night before
so
uh yeah i got the calls you know you got
to go on like a strict cover to hold and
go get tested the day before all this
[ __ ]
but then it ended up being the miley
cyrus and the uh
yeah dolly parton one and then the dudes
from scrubs the uh zac
yeah the two t-mobile commercials so
that was just another huge
week of experience under my belt and
it feels really good now because the
team is really like
trust me now more so than last year i
was becoming new marty yeah whereas
they're doing things that where i'm the
only camera in certain instances now and
pulling up the talon over to the side
and doing interviews just bts for the
first time it's like stopping the
production making sure i get a shot the
talent doing a monologue all that type
of [ __ ] so
so behind all this is this business that
we're doing marty's doing a whole nother
thing yeah so two super bowl commercials
i got on youtube yesterday i
screenshotted it for you
they had both of them on the very top i
was it's [ __ ] funny because i was
passed out during an actual super bowl
i saw it like
through those texts and [ __ ] i was so
tired because it man
the whole week because
you got to be there the call time on
some of these shoots is like all right
you got to be there at six in the
morning and it's like yeah yeah it's
like
an hour and a half away or whatever it's
like all right well we'll be there no
problem but in the background all this
too we had another cool thing going on
which was this netflix show yes that i
got brought in on but that was in from
the cold and from the cold on netflix
that
i've been working on the past month and
it was i mean it charted at the top of
the chart netflix charts and the
globally it was like an international
show it was number three in the world
like all week the first week came out
last week
and then in the top ten charts in like
multiple countries russia poland spain
america so it was a little background
though yeah yeah shows about
show's about a russian spy who's in
america living as a housewife and then
gets reactivated and blackmailed into
being a spy oh [ __ ] i didn't know that
much
yeah
oh [ __ ] yeah it's got an awesome kill
bill 2 types yeah yeah it's got it's
like hillbill meets born identity meets
like it's internet you know
is it in english with subtitles or is it
some of it
a lot of it takes place in spain russia
but it was really cool because the dude
that owned that the creator of the show
was a good friend of mine somebody that
was kind of yeah adam that we've been
kind of talking about the person that
put me in position to film on super bowl
commercials and [ __ ]
so you know
how did you beat him
interesting story through a mutual
friend of mine
so i had a mutual friend of mine
that was going through a really horrible
time in life
yeah okay we'll just leave it let's
leave it at that we'll leave it at that
a very famous person getting canceled if
you could imagine somebody on top of the
world and then having a really really
tough go at it
it was that but in the midst of him
going through a bunch of really you know
a really hard situation he connected me
with uh adam who's a legit hollywood
show runner yeah meaning he
he runs shows he's a writer director
uh he he creates shows so he was looking
to start a podcast for anthony anderson
the actor oh this was through adam and
everything yeah
so there was a couple months there right
the money started before we started this
that i thought i was going to be
producing a podcast for anthony anderson
also anthony ended up taking like i
don't know it's the late show or the
late late show he's doing he's got some
tv shows and stuff that he's doing now
we didn't end up doing it but
adam was so impressed by how i pitched
myself i was up against a lot of people
for that role all up against companies
and i went in there just me and you know
if it was gonna if it were to have
happened i would have been the producer
of it and they talked to you for [ __ ]
yeah about it i was in competition for
months over the [ __ ]
and uh
he was so impressed by that he put me on
to not a sports show
which had you know was my first real
commercial thing where i'm on set
filming there's you know 100 person crew
and we got real celebrities coming on
and it's me one one-on-one there's a lot
of trust there and it was a big [ __ ] and
sharp shannon sharp is a a greek god
giant yeah shannon sharp was the only
one that i was like damn this fool was
[ __ ] huge
but that was paul pierce travis kelsey
wasn't big that was a different shoot
travis kelsey was big it was big right
yeah travis kelsey was big
so uh but you know the we've talked
about this before but the not a sports
show really was my big push into like
celebrity bts filming behind the scenes
and really being involved with the
production crew yeah and it was one of
the biggest things ever in my career and
it really established like how he was uh
how uh sean was talking about um dj poo
putting him in position exactly like
that
yeah like okay you're in position now
it's on you to go crush it yeah go
[ __ ] crush it or i mean why would i
bring you on yeah and because i crushed
it so hard on that not a sports show
they started hiring me for more [ __ ] so
that's when i did after that right after
that this is right as we're starting the
podcast we did the anthony anderson
travis kelsey super bowl commercial gwen
stefani adam levine blake shelton
commercial right in the same week
and then since then i've been going and
doing you know little things we did the
microsoft commercial i filmed a couple
of pilots and stuff with them
but uh coming into this week yeah it was
huge i was doing the netflix thing and
that was like a literally a daily
obligation for a full month seven super
bowl commercials and we filmed two
podcasts all kinds of episodes same
[ __ ] week yeah so this past month has
been a blur like when i say i was passed
out sleeping during the super bowl i
really was i get it
that that week for me was
[ __ ] too i'm not in a bad way because
everything's good but just film on top
of filming on top of filming and editing
and editing and editing
yeah it takes a toll yeah and we had
yeah some big yola videos coming out in
the adventures channel all that like
it's been a right up until yesterday
yeah it's till today
i was just like damn i finally almost
i'm kind of caught up right now
it's been it's been a [ __ ] blur guys
and
uh you know
i'll leave that at that because there's
a lot of little mini stories in that
triumph we'll get to that in a minute
all right well try
those are good super bowl commercials so
uh pretty [ __ ] baller
guys let's get on to this next part this
is another triumph except i'ma take over
this part this is a win but this is my
win you guys ready
i put it down
i'll just leave you with this
all right all right went to las vegas
uh for champs champs is
a convention you guys have heard of like
the high times event where you go and
you can buy weed and smoke weed
champs is the convention in las vegas
for wholesaler buyers only
so if you don't know what that means
like um
say i own a 7-eleven right how do i get
pepsi how do i get [ __ ] nerd ropes
how do i get chips
i go to those companies online or
whatever pick it out show them my
business license wholesale number since
i'm a store i'm allowed to buy wholesale
wholesale i get it at half off what
retail say i buy a soda it's three
dollars i get it for 150 and i sell it
to you for three dollars
that's how the world works okay
so
we went to the wholesale convention
called champs in vegas but it's for weed
[ __ ]
only
imagine walking into a building the
building was an uh was a like a eighth
of a mile long i believe
no it was a quarter mile long or fourth
of a mile long or some [ __ ] i can't
remember but from the front and back it
was .8 miles or some [ __ ] it was pretty
ridiculous
anyway
it's only weed [ __ ] smoke shop smoke
shop wholesale
guys that sell legal shrooms guys that
sell legal spice dudes that sell delta
eight cbd companies
so we had a booth right the first time
i've ever had a booth
that's not just like
hundreds people just chilling taking
pictures trying to hang out like when i
go to boost do people like yo i follow
this [ __ ] you want to smoke my
[ __ ] yeah with cove but it's different
but fools will walk up like you don't
check his dab take his [ __ ] dab it
the booths are dope because we still
push trees gear it was sick
this time i went for the dopest shop
it's the brand we started i told you
guys about the hhc hhc is basically
a weed substitute you guys have heard of
delta eight you guys have heard of that
this is the new version of that it's
called hhc all right
it's just not thc that's it gets you
high all the same things
except it doesn't uh it's legal it's
federally legal in all states you can
ship it it's just like cbd you can ship
cbd so
we went there long explanation but i'll
tell you guys why long explanation our
booth you saw the booth marty it had my
[ __ ] face so [ __ ] sick me and
april were like damn look at this
[ __ ] thing it had the close-up super
colorful i didn't shine shots before i
walked in with brochures and [ __ ] it was
so wrong we were professional like the
first time we've been professional about
our booth the whole background had my
face holding up some [ __ ] with a big ass
pen
smoke yeah so when you walk by like yo
that's the flat follows big-ass face on
the side of this booth and then it was
cool it was dope anyway
we're there everything's going good
and
one of our me our partners brings up a
guy i'm like oh nice to meet you man
turns out he's our banker
so when you sell things
that are frowned upon glass
hemp products bank of america does not
take your money they will not let it
happen
so you have to find a private bank that
lets this work
we found a private bank
and they've been doing all of our
transactions for us we have to pay them
per transaction so on so forth
the guy comes up and he's like yo man i
love your videos blah blah turns out
he's one of our banker guys
a couple minutes later
the owner of the bank
comes to our booth because he flew in to
meet us
he's like i'll go to vegas i need to
meet these guys that are [ __ ]
crushing it anyway
the guy wanted to meet us because he
watched our videos and went oh we we
gotta we gotta meet the people that
we're working with and they're like [ __ ]
it go to las vegas
god damn
the owner this is the actual banker oh
man and the white in the in the blue
suit
real cool guy
but i went
oh my god you came down to see my high
ass all right i [ __ ] love this the
other banker was like yo you know
everyone at the office loves your [ __ ]
we're at doing all our [ __ ] we'll just
throw it on like
amazing it's like podcasts podcast is
crap i'm like oh my god these guys are
really watching our [ __ ] content all
right cool bankers are [ __ ] loving
our [ __ ] so
we did really good
all right one of my partners hatch house
i'm just gonna say this story real quick
one of my partners from hatches we had
to go talk to a distributor and he
distributes on the whole east coast the
biggest one he distributes hundreds of
thousands of units we lock that in we're
[ __ ] crushing
so
we have to meet the guy because he's
flying in to the booth
yes guys we were on on some adult
meeting [ __ ] like no there's a meeting
we don't care about everybody walking
around wholesale that's great we need
the distributors the distributors are
the big guys and then here's the
wholesalers distributors are the [ __ ]
key holders
so we go to the booth
and we have to like convince the guy
like no no we have a big following
because the thing that separates us from
everyone else in the [ __ ] whole
building
is that i have a following that i've
been doing the weed [ __ ] for
and i have a brand under me everyone
else is selling really good but they
don't have a brand there's no name
there's nothing behind it so the
incentive to buy from us is like yo
i follow this [ __ ] dude these are
gonna sell like crazy people come in all
the time talking about this guy so it
works well
we're walking to the booth and i'm with
hash house we have to meet the guy
remember we have to convince this man
turns out this was my friend hash
house's roommate when they were young
hasn't seen the guy in eight years it
doesn't know what he's been doing they
used to make hash together
as kids
like 16 18 year old kids making hash
together so ridiculous so he walks up
and goes
what the [ __ ] and he goes wait you're
the [ __ ] you're the distributed
buyer he goes
are you [ __ ] kidding me
and he goes i don't care lock it in
right on the spot locked in everything
crazy like we're gonna drop our big i
won't say the competitor name the other
biggest ajc brands that we're gonna drop
them anyway it's like now you're our guy
like what the [ __ ]
what are the odds
childhood hash making would come into
play in legal money
so we locked that in locked in the
biggest dude in the midwest locked in
the other biggest dude in the north of
the pacific northwest did you have to
pitch to them
the same i mean they kind of walked in
and it was done the big guy we were like
oh we got to talk to him it just
happened to be hash house's old friend
and he's like oh my tattoos his brother
did
so like they know each other all of his
[ __ ] body art is from the guy's
brother like they
they used to do [ __ ] together i just
thought it was the craziest story like
what are the [ __ ]
and they're from florida this is las
vegas
they haven't seen each other since they
were kids this is that good youtube
karma coming back finally right right
like finally like all the years of
getting [ __ ] with like wait i follow
that guy
oh no give me a give me an order bike
yeah because they're like yo we're
selling everything and it sells every
day
wouldn't it be better if we sold the
from the guy we're watching
yeah it's like we're all selling uh
basketball sneakers but this company's
got [ __ ] steph curry over here
wearing their [ __ ] wearing the [ __ ] and
he owns it like oh
kick it down
so this is not the whole story
so as we're talking
going great it's going on as i'm talking
to the banker
he lets me in on a little thing he goes
man i just won't let you know man
we had to come meet you guys because
like we never seen nothing like this
happen we've never seen a company grow
so fast
and
that was a month and 12 days in
this is the triumph all right
without wholesale we haven't done any
wholesale yet it's just retail from you
guys
we're the fifth largest brand in america
oh
i was just taking it in that just scared
me
let's go number five
of cbd
delta 8
and hhc
all of those no matter what it is
we're number five in america
without the wholesale
and i found out their numbers were right
behind them we're right behind them
monthly and the thing is that's their
wholesale numbers too damn and this is
just our retail we haven't even touched
a wholesale cell yet and you haven't
even put out the dabs and [ __ ] that
right we just did we just just put out
the concentrates yeah thedopashop.com
check that [ __ ] out i'm not gonna go too
hard wait it's legal what's legal you
might as well be selling goddamn
tomatoes or something yeah it's it's
literally selling your clothes
dopeyshop.com go check it out it's
[ __ ] legal to your door so um does it
[ __ ] i get a million comments does the
does it ship to canada nope usa only all
right canada uh banned hac a bunch of
[ __ ] house i think it'll [ __ ] up their
legal weed sales it's really what's
going on
uh because we got like 100 000 people
last month trying to buy from canada hmm
god damn
just nope doesn't work doesn't work
doesn't how many dm's we had to respond
to what the [ __ ] oh bro i'm sorry your
laws in your own country tells me no um
so that's the triumph guys
we're the fifth largest company
officially that's insane as of as it
should be i mean
so glad that that's so stoked it's
happening it's working
oh another good piece of information uh
the 405 this month probably another week
uh if you're on the 405 heading anywhere
south from la
look for this
this face
just got a billboard huh let's go got a
billboard and it's going to be me
with a [ __ ] pen
and in the smoke it's going to say our
website
insane
now [ __ ] it
even though it's not going to help sales
yeah like [ __ ] it throw it in here
victory yep the moral victory um so yeah
guys uh fifth largest company i don't
know that's [ __ ] amazing thank you
guys so much thank you thank you thank
you and uh
oh this will be out we just dropped
carts
not like cartridges that people love
like once you screw on your own pen we
just dropped them the job tonight nice
so you could get the disposable pens or
just the carts nice yeah people been
bugging and they're cheaper so people
are gonna love that [ __ ] um so yeah
that's the win sorry sorry i know that
took a long time i'm very sorry
i'm just excited
this is some entrepreneurial [ __ ]
like chess you're doing right here this
is some high level [ __ ] you've probably
laid into it's always so funny every
time something crazy happens i go
i look down like i'm wearing vans and
it's high
cool as soon as they're like you're the
fifth largest company
look back at my face just high as [ __ ]
[Laughter]
did it my way yeah
yes
[ __ ] yeah um
i've been very lucky
um
yeah i think it's really fun when i was
on the phone with that billionaire
[ __ ] if you've seen the story
time and i'm just like with a [ __ ]
joint i'm talking to a billionaire about
this company this is insane
they see something like not the one you
told to suck your dick either by the way
right not the one i told to [ __ ] suck
my dick no no he's a different guy he's
not a billionaire he's a millionaire oh
it's a big difference
the b is the difference um
so yeah everything's going really good
with the company thank you guys so much
super [ __ ] stoked
are you ready
are you ready
here we go we're gonna get into the
tribulations
marty want to take it away i'm still
hurt over this [ __ ] okay i know i'm
still [ __ ] hurt i'm sorry it's it's
literally the worst thing that could
possibly happen to you
as a videographer besides getting also
jumped
okay yeah yeah yeah yeah besides like yo
i also got jumped after
that be the worst [ __ ] thing ever
take it away here's the tribulations
marty so
first first thing during this epic run
that we've been on all right actually
after the adam l episode
right after i was on [ __ ] high alert
because i was booked to go film the rock
the following day [ __ ] rock
i'm [ __ ] slipping
i'm slipping
all right so so for everybody out there
in the comments when you went you guys
interview on the rock soon no remember
when someone i think adam said the rock
and i went
we talked about it i was like this is
what we're referring to the next day was
marty's [ __ ] so he had a super bowl
commercial come out for his new for his
company
that you know the that's what we're
talking about but this was like a unique
situation because if you look at the
commercial it looks like a bts shoot
they shot it as bts basically so this
was one of the first times that
literally immediately after the adam
mill episode ended i got up and had one
took a video call in the back room
and i was on there for like an hour and
a half because they were it was the
first time they were like all right
you're gonna be one of the main camera
angles not not only were they coaching
me up on with a shot list and like
you're gonna be one of the only people
that's allowed in because kovid
things was so high with the shoot
normally they're high and intense
in terms of that rock now having to get
tested and
all the [ __ ] you have to wear and how
you you know are on set and [ __ ] but
this was even
stricter to the point that i had to get
tested the day before and the night
before and the day before and then the
day of right yeah there would have been
two
so we did add a mill episode i did the
um
video call with them and they're like
getting me ready they're like yo you
gotta make sure you're on your [ __ ]
[ __ ] basically there's really no room
for like
mess-ups with this you gotta be really
on point because him and his team are
like
they're they you know they need you to
really be on point just kind of you know
saying the rock is gonna [ __ ] you up if
you [ __ ] his shot
yeah just make sure you bring your a
game is really what they were driving
home i was so [ __ ] fired up i
remember it was like uh
before a huge game or something i'm
ready for that i'm listen i'm ready for
that you know they're telling me that
i'm like just say no more man i'm
[ __ ]
on full stealth mode in there like a
goddamn ninja
so
i left here it was late i didn't get
home till like 11 30 and i had to
be back out at like my call time was
like say
i don't know eight or whatever
about midnight rolls around and i get an
email sorry you tested positive
can't come tomorrow
and it just sunk my [ __ ] soul
because i had taken a test earlier that
day
and here i am with zero symptoms
whatsoever feeling like a savage getting
ready to go murder that next day
and they're like it you can't even test
again because i'm like it's got to be a
[ __ ] fluke this [ __ ] the thing
says right on it it might not be
accurate like let me come test again i
don't have
because i had been on hold for like a
week so i've been out in the garage yeah
he was quarantined from his whole family
just in case i was wearing a mask in my
own house
the thing is you weren't even positive
well i mean my my result came back
positive yeah but then you've had to
test again it was [ __ ] negative yeah
and the two before were negative yeah
i've had a slew of negative [ __ ]
results that's the only time i've ever
tested positives yeah that's why i'm
saying you're so [ __ ] careful with
this the fact that they went
well i mean there's a slight line but
that was that's that's just how high
that's just how high the um level that
looks like they just tested you and they
just test you again and they're like for
for luck yeah
so that that exactly that hurt because i
was like [ __ ]
man that's so just
be such a uh
such a notch on the belt
but something just turned off yeah yeah
the sound i gotta i'll kick this back on
oh okay okay um
it's got some new settings on this new
camera here
um
anyway so yeah that was a major major
one because i didn't know how many if i
was gonna get called for any other super
bowl commercials dirty [ __ ]
don't call his ass back yeah i didn't
know if they were gonna like
i was just so distraught it was just
[ __ ] like
as a videographer to get uh like a name
like that on your resume i mean granted
i was booked it was done set in stone
but just i would have loved to want to
make that connection and just get that
under my belt nice to meet you sir yeah
yeah my kids would have been so [ __ ]
excited
um
that's not even the worst part no that
was actually that's child's play
compared to the [ __ ] real
tribulations that went down here okay
yeah yeah go ahead i'll do the buffering
but elevated music for everyone at home
marty's uh pressing play on the camera
[Music]
i don't know elevator music
um
i'm just gonna sing kodak black in
spanish
i know i saw that damn he got shot just
coming to the super bowl [ __ ]
um
yeah so walmart is changing this camera
how you guys doing how are you good if
you're at that stoplight that sucks i'm
sorry if you're in traffic i'm [ __ ]
really sorry if you're at school
keep it up i guess
if you really want to do it keep going
and if you're at work at least you're
getting [ __ ] paid
all right and for everyone else at home
chilling
me me too just hanging out here all
right so uh we just got a brand new
camera open it up 30 minutes before
we started this episode that's why the
camera we didn't change the setting also
do you want to know why we have a new
camera
ready
go yeah man
all right so yeah we got a brand new
[ __ ] camera and it's amazing but i
gotta figure out the internal
temperature settings here to get this
[ __ ] to not overheat is overheated
yeah but it's a setting that's got a
whole new menu system so i don't know it
yet yeah
but this is a major upgrade as far as
cameras go this is the big brother to
the camera my first camera that i bought
two years ago
and a way better lens we could do we
should probably should do a whole
separate video on this
because it's a big [ __ ] difference in
terms of what i'm able to actually cover
now with this lens
so
set this yeah set the setting here so on
my last day of filming this week
it was the last day it was for the zac
braff uh
donald azon commercial the t-mobile
commercial we basically they took over a
whole neighborhood for this shoot
and i was with them the day before
filming their rehearsal because it was
like a musical
so that was really cool because it was
just me and them basically there was no
other crew there and they were doing
choreography and they're actually
singing in a recording studio and i was
like in there with them while they were
singing the song that ended up being on
the commercials
and then the next day we were out on set
you know and they took over a whole
neighborhood
uh to film this so that was a real
neighborhood it looked like a back lot
but they just took the whole [ __ ] over
so i you know i did this uh did the
whole thing it was like a 12-hour day
and then right after it we had the
system of a down corn concert which we
get into in a little bit yeah which is
where we
the venue was where i actually filmed
not a sports show at bank of california
stadium which is a little loud which was
[ __ ] cool uh so i did this whole
day it was a really long day and then
you know i ended up walking to my car
there was a shuttle but i was
rushing and i didn't want to wait for
the shuttle so i have all my [ __ ] and i
walked like i don't know maybe a mile to
the and me rosie and his wife april are
already at the venue waiting for the
show to start
he's the only one there
and he can't really go in until he gets
there because i have all the tickets
yeah so we're like yo marty if you could
as soon as you're stuck
hurry back you're also 45 minutes away
from you yeah i've been going i've been
up since like 4 45 5 in the morning get
out there do the shoot yeah and then um
yeah so then i'm hustling to the car
now
i have my car with me and not my truck i
usually have the truck but it's i got
some issues going so i have my car with
me so i get to the parking lot where i'm
in the crew parking lot i have my three
big bags with me i put two of them in
the trunk and then i like change my
clothes i get on the phone with april
and
pull off and head downtown to the
[ __ ] corn concert
we go to the corn concert it's [ __ ]
amazing awesome one of the coolest
things ever
that you know to see chavo out there
like that was just crazy like what a
[ __ ] performer when my first rock
concert amazing
we do that we get back home and then i
go to get my [ __ ] out of the trunk it's
like 1 30 in the morning open the trunk
[ __ ] heart drops because i realize my
pelican case isn't in the trunk one of
them so i have two bags and a pelican
case the pelican case has my camera
let's go over this that's my camera both
my lenses my other camera my 360 camera
all my i know that i didn't know that
until today either
all my
accessories and screws and cleaning gear
all my [ __ ] probably like eight thousand
dollars worth of gear
a and the pelican case itself
now
uh is it's not in there it's not in the
trunk so a million things run through my
mind did somebody steal my [ __ ] at the
concert
did
like a million thoughts run through my
mind but then i realized
i didn't put it in the [ __ ] trunk
before i left for the concert
still in the parking lot
because i went to rushing i was changing
your clothes yeah there was ours it was
[ __ ] stupid there was a mirror in the
trunk and i'm like let me change my
shirt i'll put the shirt down on the
mirror then i'll put the case on top of
it just trying to avoid a [ __ ]
argument with april over this goddamn
mirror um she's navigating to the
[ __ ]
venue
uh i'm talking to her and i forgot to
put my [ __ ] case in the trunk
so now it's like two in the morning and
i'm like freaking out because that's a
loss that i just can't take right now
we're
still in full remodel on the house
basically we're in the middle of doing
the uh bathroom and then we like have
the painters scheduled and [ __ ] so like
i'm just not in a position to [ __ ]
take a 8 000 loss at the moment
and uh it just killed me i didn't sleep
at all i just laid there
thinking damn it's probably i was just
say it you drove back yeah wow you
forgot to mention um yeah i mean i laid
there for a couple hours i'm like
somebody picked it up somebody had to
pick this [ __ ] up you're the f also
you're the first production person to
leave yeah so the whole team was like yo
martin you left your [ __ ]
it was in a parking lot it was a big
public parking lot but
i was probably the first one to leave
because i was [ __ ] hustling
and uh
so i was just like somebody had to have
gotten it but i didn't sleep 5 a.m rolls
around mind you i had already been out
there at 5 8 i had already let and this
is my third day in the week are
consecutively doing that [ __ ]
so i went back out there i was like
still dark out
got out there
not there
just in what was just [ __ ] like weird
where my case was in this empty parking
lot was like four to five black crows oh
that's right you're just [ __ ]
standing there just looking at me and
[ __ ] right where the case should have
been
like
[ __ ]
uh
so then i found like their little
security nobody knew nothing
and then yeah i went through all the
measures that you could one could go
through to try to find a lost [ __ ]
case and the [ __ ] hasn't come hasn't
come back yet
so uh
yeah that should that that should just
[ __ ] crush my soul
that was horrible that's the biggest i'm
really super militant and organized and
disciplined and all my [ __ ] ironically
earlier in the day i was patting myself
on the back like i never lost nothing
years never lost nothing never broke
nothing never got robbed never
nothing
all the [ __ ] i first bought is still
here in perfect condition
i was thinking that to myself earlier in
the day
and then uh
yeah i went and just did that massive
[ __ ] up
and uh
yeah then um
you were like don't worry about it don't
kill yourself we'll [ __ ] figure this
[ __ ] out
and yeah here we are with a massive
[ __ ] major upgrade brand new
everything [ __ ] it just like
it's like this someone gives you a pound
of weed a fire because you just lost two
pounds of weed it's like yo thank you
[ __ ] yeah also [ __ ]
no matter how much i love this thing
these are someone who has my [ __ ] out
there
that's the worst thing there's somebody
rolling around with uh-huh with like
your whole i'm assuming i already uh one
day it's gonna oh [ __ ] hey we have your
[ __ ] sorry i'm just assuming that that's
what oh that'd be so bomb yeah in my
mind that's what's gonna happen that's
what i said too like nah it'll pop up
it'll pop up but it's been a minute it's
been like a week and a half it's like oh
let's see
they just loaded it up because there's
such a big production like no just throw
it in there it's ours and then they'll
finally go this isn't even on the
register whose is this [ __ ] and they see
dope's usual sticker bam yeah
it could very well be there's a whole
slew of [ __ ] that could have happened
something could have i don't know it's
just so [ __ ] up
so that's what happened to marty's
camera guys
it [ __ ] died and i was bitching like
the night before not bitching but we
were at the concert and i was telling
nikita like yeah it's time for an
upgrade dude you were literally telling
our my videographer they were talking
he's like yo this one i shoot with you i
think about an upgrade i've said that to
everybody i've been saying that for so
long two hours later you realize like oh
i do need to upgrade it was the worst
drop stomach feeling you could ever
imagine i just lost a kid
[ __ ] just puts me
out of commission in super bowl season
because i was then put right back on
hold
didn't end up get getting a booking for
it but like puts me out of commission
puts the podcast out of commission
uh we went right into the show
we rented all the whole setup for
franklin's episode yeah because that
happened right before yeah
yeah yeah
wow
all that happened collab we're past it
that we passed it yeah it was a
stressful it was a stressful
past three weeks for sure
so that's what i said the worst thing
that can happen to a videographer is
losing everything
that's what so what stung even a little
bit more is that i almost on several
occasions almost bought air tags i
didn't have air tag on my [ __ ] i had it
in the [ __ ] cart 10 times and i'm
like i'll just get it i'll get one later
i don't need one
so i load it up on the [ __ ] tech now
like
don't steal my [ __ ] and basically yeah
yeah i'm hoping that we're gonna be able
to have it covered by insurance but
it's just i'm definitely about to get a
whole separate insurance for all my [ __ ]
yeah for sure you need it
um
what do we have marty
about 50 50.
we're doing a great job today i'm just
going to say that i'm trying to tighten
these up a little bit and we're doing a
good [ __ ] job
hey what's up guys taking a quick moment
to talk about one of our longtime
sponsors this is manscaped so let me
introduce something to you guys this is
the ultra premium collection from
manscape this is for head to toe
grooming every single thing you can
think about is in this package so before
i tell you what's in the package like i
always do go to manscape.com
www.manscape.com forward slash yola
that's 20 off of this package anything
else you buy plus free shipping you
cannot get a better deal anywhere else
for manscape use our code yolo so up
first is the deodorant and no this is
not for your balls this is actually for
your arms the second thing is the
hydrating body moisturizer if you guys
are like me if you're any other dude
yeah right now my knuckles are pretty
ashy so the third thing and also i mean
i guess you could use this on your balls
too you probably should actually okay
this is aloe vera and sea salt mixture
this is the new body wash for manscapes
and the free gift for this is a three
pack of the manscape lip balm all or
maybe the same ingredients vitamin e
peppermint and eucalyptus oil so once
again guys go to
www.manscape.com forward slash yola
that's 20 off of all the [ __ ] i just
talked about plus free shipping as
always guys thank you so much for
supporting the brands that support us
back to the episode
that should hurt the [ __ ] talk about
i know that [ __ ] sucks so uh that's what
happened with marty it's really [ __ ]
lame it missed the rock missed his [ __ ]
but we're back we're back it's a new
week we're crushing it you're done
within from the cold you got more time
yes we're gonna crush it all right this
is this
we're gonna do a good job
uh so on to the next part this is my
tribulation so i'll make it brief
i'll make it real brief because [ __ ] the
camera is so much better um here we go
you guys during the goblin episode
me and him were taught the recent goblin
episode me and him were talking i'm like
yo snapchat's the only app that like
just lets me do my thing doesn't [ __ ]
with me i used to post 100 pounds on
there it didn't matter
but recently the past year and [ __ ] i
haven't really been posting weed or
nothing just like what i'm doing
maybe it's the hhc i don't know what it
was even though it's legal but
snapchat deleted me alright they deleted
my original [ __ ] snapchat account
just a little backstory on that snapchat
account
it was number two
ranked number two in this entire state
for retention
because people like to watch it
and they'll watch it over and over and
over
so number one is kylie jenner because
she's famous
number two was me
[ __ ] shocking
and number three is cardi b because
she's [ __ ] famous
i'm up against girls that show their
body i did pretty good all right i'm
doing pretty good for stuff that
everyone wants to look at versus not
everybody wants to see we [ __ ] but
everyone wants to seem like pretty girls
i did pretty good all right for just me
[ __ ] a little me
uh
i wasn't naked i'll say that um i got
deleted they deleted it
[ __ ] deleted it
i it was like over 250 million views
this [ __ ] is equally as devastating
actually it's got to be more because
because my numbers monthly i was getting
like one to two million views a month
right my retention is 99
like they what people watch it 99 of the
way that's why my [ __ ] was ranked so
high on that social blade [ __ ]
and um
yeah they took it away
but that sucks because my snapchat is
the only thing that keeps my other
social medias alive when they get
deleted so if i get deleted on instagram
i post on my snapchat so i have a huge
[ __ ] following on snap go hey check
out my new instagram swipe up follow it
and that's how i get 10 000 [ __ ]
followers in a couple minutes
that's how it works
but now snapchat's gone and then i lost
my instagram again
then at the same time youtube's going
hard on my age restriction
so now it's like yo i'm i'm invisible
what do i do
so
that's what happened to me i thought it
was a bummer because with uh we just did
a new drop for the dopa shop of all the
concentrates
and that
the video got age restricted quick on
youtube so the views were suck
snapchat i can't post about it my new
snapchat
is not getting
[Music]
one-tenth of my views
so
they got me they got me good but i'll be
back all right i don't give a [ __ ] i
will be back
i don't give a [ __ ] just want to let you
guys know yeah i don't have that
snapchat anymore my new snapchat marty
maybe we could pop it over the screen
for everyone here boom this is my new
snapchat for everyone out there it's the
dopest yola
and i know it's really hard to be like
am i following the right account
just go to my instagram
click the link and then you always the
only snapchat i have is is in the link
right there that's the only way i can
say it because the dopa seola is the
name but somebody can make the same name
with an extra a and you didn't notice
and now they're just showing you
buy packs like that's why people that's
why i hate isn't that why they deleted
your [ __ ] because then i don't know
there's so many people doing that i mean
i've had that snapchat for seven years
so i don't i don't know
i used to show hella packs on there so
now you wanna [ __ ] with me i'm just like
doing the podcast and like selling
real legal hhc pens like all right
anyway um the other little piece which
is insignificant to the [ __ ] camera
uh is the dopa shop our brand uh the
instagram got deleted again for the
fifth time
they keep taking us down even though
it's a legal company legal
[ __ ] federally legal
that's like taking down my makeup page
if i had one kind of [ __ ] i should does
it to take it down and then put it back
up again yeah but it's been gone for
like two weeks now
so we lost our page again for the fifth
time it just it's just [ __ ] up it's
like damn you really [ __ ] with our
sale or drop
i think they're waiting for all you
dropping dropping to drop
gone
are you driving a new drop oh you're
making a new video in youtube restricted
i think that's what they're doing to me
but i don't give a [ __ ] um
so yeah that's my tribulations that i'm
working through right now uh
insignificant to losing the whole setup
of marty's camera but also awesome
because this new setup is badass yes so
oh i have another joint did you just
roll joy on camera
oh yeah you're official
you're official now
you're official are you ready
um so marty touched on it earlier
shout out to chavo all right shout out
to shabbo from system of down for having
us out
i'm just going to touch on a little more
guys i've
i love system of down i love corn
go through all the tanaya yearbooks it's
just alternating
shirts with me just a little more brown
because the summer a little whiter
because the winter and just
corn system down corn system with down
shirts just
i love them
so
chilling with shovels really awesome
like yo you're the bass player to my one
of my favorite bands of all time also
you're [ __ ] cool just in general shaw
was a cool [ __ ] he's super nice
dude and he told us marty bring your
wife thomas bring rosie let's go to the
[ __ ] show get you guys passes i'm
like [ __ ] yeah so this is that night
marty lost his cameras april's april's
corn corn fanatic yeah so his wife april
was just like yo no way
let's go
so i've been wanting to see them since i
was a kid
so sixth grade fifth to sixth grade is
when i was like yo sis of a down show
would be so sick
corn would be so sick and here i am in
my early thirties finally getting to go
and [ __ ] child was like yeah you
should come like yeah i went to the
front we got our passes i'm like dude
this is awesome
so the show is going on jonathan dave's
core and all that come out [ __ ] crush
it i'm gonna be honest
if i close my eyes
i couldn't tell if it was live or not it
was so good it was this voice is so
[ __ ] accurate
it sounded like the cd
all right i was shocked fool came out in
a leather kilt like yo this is what i've
been waiting for [ __ ] yeah so we're
getting there we're sitting there
watching the show system of down comes
on it's [ __ ] amazing marty's the only
person in the entire row sitting
and watching everybody else is like why
the [ __ ]
is marty's first rock show ever the
lights were [ __ ] tripping me out
they're going to the music yeah so me
and marty's sitting there look at their
lighting system yeah look it moves we
need that at the show
we're just trying our best to what
their lights move because their lights
were
unfucking real they're [ __ ] that's
shifting casting light behind them i
went that's the look it was as much of
the show as the music
how much the lights were doing they were
going to the [ __ ] fog
it was very cool never see i've been to
a lot of rock shows coolest rock show
i've ever been to
they really crushed it and then when
system of down came on i'm just sitting
there and like
little me he's like no way yeah they
come out and i told y'all later i'm like
yo
you look so happy and seriously that
[ __ ] loves this never stop
moving the entire time the whole show
he's everybody else moving around and
stuff but no
there's full war dunks and he's just on
stage [ __ ] crushing it jumping around
doing just running around this like dude
you could tell one of the last rock
stars like how many more there's not
many there's not many left
that are in action it's really [ __ ]
sad and weird to say like
there's no more rock bands
like there won't be a generation of kids
that grew up on that type of [ __ ] like
what was going on in that arena never
again never again and every one of those
people in that [ __ ] building next to
us was just going saying the same thing
we were like what the [ __ ]
because i was losing my [ __ ] seeing this
like
oh my god
oh [ __ ] i remember sixth graders oh man
these guys are so sick
and now it's like yo i'm finally [ __ ]
here it was so cool to see you so
excited oh my god april had a [ __ ]
epic meltdown right before because she
was so excited
she was so [ __ ] excited
and then it's like it's it's a really
big venue and you had to like park we
all parked at different places and we're
kind of like
flustered just trying to find each other
in the first place it was so hard and i
couldn't hear and like she had to go
back you were already inside she had to
go back they told her to like she had to
put her purse in the car
trips
four back and forth treats yeah it ended
up started it it was getting so
stressful because it's like oh you're oh
[ __ ] your vaccination card oh you left
your license and we ended up sprinting
back and forth [ __ ] four times in the
car
halfway through the [ __ ] corn set we
ended up getting in
but then it was just like the excitement
was crazy
and i was man to see that many people
together was weird
let alone just just everybody tapping
into that [ __ ] that they grew up on
together like
that energy was crazy unless they do
another show they're not going to play
another like another tour they're we're
not going to see a system of a down show
until they do like rock and roll hall of
fame damn
what think about it they don't as a
first door they've done it like 15
[ __ ] years
crazy
we saw some dope [ __ ] that night yeah
it was
most legendary rock song of all time
yeah like bro it was just really i'm
sorry i'm sorry if we're boring you guys
out there but
it was [ __ ] awesome i haven't been to
a show in a very long time the last rock
show i went to was
blink 22 green day when i was [ __ ]
13.
and that's really not a rock show these
this is the [ __ ] rock show a show
like that hits different now when you
see fans connecting with the with the
performers like that it's like wow these
are real can we just give it up to the
[ __ ] camera guys
whoever ran that show
oh my god beautiful crushed it so
[ __ ] beautiful it was unbelievable
the fades
they knew what they were doing yeah they
knew what they was like no no it's a
movie yeah like play your music so let
me [ __ ] film it that's how they were
that's how i felt like
who directs this this is the live that's
all i could think about i was just
staring at like who's directing because
i had a huge screen like
someone's sitting back there from the
nfl yeah and just going no no i'll take
the live switch nfl i don't know
but i mean he was crushing it so hard
dude
everything they did anyway sorry keep
going on and on about it and then right
after marty's whole world crash
[Laughter]
right after that when marty realized
little did we know that in that moment
yeah my [ __ ] was being taken
oh
it's okay it's okay so the show was
[ __ ] awesome marty's first rock show
and it puts in perspective just people
when you see like thirty thousand people
at once it was weird
so many [ __ ] people and in on the
floor like that in a long time because
we were up to like in the stands more
like in the section and like the floor
was just
off sea of people i was imagining
everybody on their phones in the
premiere watching the podcast like we
fill up the stadium yeah easy like
the franklin episode is like
depending on which stadium two stadiums
worth of people right
now just awesome i know when you say
that i'm like wow yeah
that's very cool to think about [ __ ]
yeah having people sit down and go
they know all about your intro that's
trucking crazy
um yeah man so marty's first show my
favorite show i've been to shout out to
shavo once again thank you for making
that [ __ ] possible
that was [ __ ] made it made a sneak
appearance in the latest yola video too
yes the letter yeah bro how random was
that we were outside looking at colors
on cars and shovel drivers is that yeah
just [ __ ]
[ __ ] with me but
fanned out what are the odds this man's
driving by me
right it was just funny so check out the
adventures of yola channel the car we
customized the whole thing
sick ass [ __ ] video so [ __ ] sick
it's a badass video go check that [ __ ]
out how much time you filmed that over
the course of like three months
i probably put in like 100 hours on this
video
with everything and waiting and doing
this like 300 hours just
realistically yeah but like worth it
very worth it um
on to the next piece marty we're over an
hour guys i wanted to keep this like
it's the catch-up episode all right like
i didn't want to go let's do three hours
today tell six stories like
we'll leave you guys one more
it's not not today not today that's not
what you're doing we got to line up we
got to book some more guests we got to
figure out these next stretch looks like
this is a catch your breath episode yes
this is the catch up how you guys doing
hey wasn't that tight yeah yeah that's
what this episode is it wasn't that
[ __ ] crazy yeah this one is um
so quick new quick some quick news for
push trees me and rosie have been doing
push through since 2013.
the end of 2013 so realistically like a
month into that so 2014.
like going on seven eight years going
eight to nine years almost
we packed every order touched every bag
sealed every single thing printed every
order
every email
every return every [ __ ] shipment
every 13 [ __ ] hour packing day
every day yes delay
every day waiting on them to show up and
they never did so they're a bit like
like the episode of seinfeld when kramer
makes the [ __ ]
uh cable guy wait for days that's us all
right
so the reason i'm saying that is rosie
and i go hard we do everything
we hired our first employee all right i
hired our very first employee ever
i haven't packed a package and almost
two weeks
all right
[Music]
i haven't touched a package in almost
two [ __ ] weeks and the other day it
came to realization as when i was
sitting in the room filming with nikita
adobe's yola video and they go hey i'm
gonna start working on the orders don't
wait oh my god
by the time i'm done with the video the
orders are done
because usually like you know five hours
filming all right let's go four hours of
[ __ ] packing orders it's 12.
i gotta edit for at least five hours
now it's five in the morning oh i gotta
film tomorrow twelve
[ __ ] like there is no time there's no
time to do stuff when you have to do it
all
so shout out to jade uh she is now our
first employee ever super [ __ ]
awesome she's crashing and doing all
emails
ah it's just so much easier to run life
uh super cool on to the next i love how
you're putting your friends in position
right now yeah oh uh jade is ratchet
man's fiance
all right she works at a law office and
does all of their stuff and went
hey you want to quit your job and work
for us yeah like i smoke backwards
yeah backwards i walked out yet the
other day first xl changed you smoking a
[ __ ] backwood and she was packing
orders
i love it this is amazing so if you
smell backwoods on your
on the outside of your package i'm sorry
we'll try this maybe i should probably
not do that
[ __ ]
anyway i thought it was really great
just walked out and saw this
yes
um because i was leaving a no jumper
yesterday i'm like
thanks for doing the orders while i go
do this interview
[ __ ] amazing how it should be oh my
god it freed up my life it's not even
free of my life i just got some time
back
i'm always rushing and then it's like oh
the dope is shop oh that has to take
five more hours of my day oh [ __ ] all
this oh [ __ ] that's why the eventual
channel is just dead i didn't touch it
for so long i didn't have time
we got super smack j crush on the
[ __ ] oh yeah oh yeah so i hired okay
another first
i hired a social media manager never
have i done that ever in life ever we
answer every dm do every comment do
every post do everything even though
it's not a lot it's a lot to keep up
with on the back end there's hundreds if
not thousands of dms
so super smack bros my homie j you've
seen him in hell of videos
hired him
he's running push trees he's running all
the social media for us he's running all
the push through social media he's
running all the dopest shop by our hac
brand he's running all that social media
the snapchat the twitters the instagrams
doing everything i haven't had to
[ __ ] post in two weeks and almost a
month now with jay
push trees i wake up like
because jay is a [ __ ] militant
ex-army guy he wakes up five in the
morning and shits like on every doing
everything in the morning it's dark out
and like uh like what all the dms are
answered oh my [ __ ] god
[Laughter]
what
it's crazy knowing like
while i'm filming everything i would
have to do after is being done
by people i trust you i mean like people
i know and trust and it's amazing so
yeah jay shout out to him shout out to
jade and jay
and uh for the past month or two even we
so
what'd marty do he made a [ __ ] thing
for
rob deer deck i'm like nah check this
out he made something else for somebody
else no check this out like here's my
resume boom i'm making it to make it i'm
gonna go like how you get your that's
how you get [ __ ] done like you know i
would love to work with uh chappelle i
don't know maybe put your [ __ ] work
in if you're an editor and go yo here's
a five minute reel i made of your past
three stand-ups and do that for some
years probably yeah it's like you know i
just wanna
show you if you guys ever need some help
i'm here for i work this is what i do
boom so we shout out to cole first off
we have to call from [ __ ] idaho
one of the states we always like if
you're like [ __ ] iowa idahos and that
sucks i'm sorry shout out to cole he
just sent marty a real of one of our
episodes right like a
minute and a half of like chopped up
like
very fun captioned with captions yeah
so marty showed me who did this it's
this guy cole so cole we started talking
to he started doing a lot of our clips a
lot of the vertical clips you see on our
instagram of just like
highlight reel of the episode that's all
we were like yo as soon as he got it we
would hire him right now
we had hundreds of people right in yeah
a hell of people he was one person
actually took the initiative to
preemptively make some clips to be like
here this is what it could look like
it's what i do just just just if you
guys ever need help here as the hiring
person have having been on both sides of
that that's the only way to do it only
way to get it done unless we're like yo
this feels so good let's just hit him up
but how often do we
we're so busy you just heard my schedule
right
you think i'm going to be scrolling on
instagram on photographers and
videographers in los angeles it's not
going to happen it takes so long to hire
somebody to even alleviate all these
problems that you're mentioning and it's
so hard to find a good reliable person
and that's a fan yeah he's a fan already
so that's what made us that's what made
me really want to bring him on and then
we gave him some time just you know see
if we could rely on him a little bit and
then he's doing good he's doing great
like we're like yo you're a good editor
[ __ ] yeah so marty and i said hey come
on no no cole said
i'm gonna come out there for a week
let's
meet talk about some [ __ ]
so shout out to cole he was here all
last week
um
what an epic [ __ ] trip for that kid
yeah yeah it was really cool because
he's a fan of all this [ __ ] so like i
had him with goblin we came over and
went and did mushrooms coal [ __ ] has
a very high tolerance for mushrooms
he ate them all didn't feel [ __ ]
i was just i was like dad i gotta go
home but i took a lot but uh
so this is what happened guys
i added about 30 this is how a video
goes ready say i make a review video on
a disney product
i i film it with nikita takes
with the b-roll of close-ups
five to ten hours which is a lot just to
smoke some weed because any youtuber can
just go that's just fire yeah let's try
this next one out boom boom 40 minutes
they're done 10 [ __ ] hour videos
because
that close up now run it back run it
back nope let's get the close up again
you got to set it up let the lazy susan
spin back let's come here new light set
up new this oh there's five
flavors
times it by five everything i just did
times it by five so
it takes a while about ten hours and
then i get the edit i take all my
footage put it in my pro my primitive
ass [ __ ] program
because i'm really bad at this
i line all the clips up so here's my
talking then i chop up all the close-ups
close-ups and then i start putting them
the close-ups over the parts of me
talking where i want it
i set up the entire video
that could take me anywhere from six to
15 hours depending on how intricate that
video is
10 hours to shoot
let's just say 10 hours to edit my part
just my part edit
so i'm 20 hours deep right
so here we go
i chop it all up i leave some [ __ ] muted
so this is like the part that marty's
going to make all sick i'd make a time
stamp here marty add the name here add a
cool montage here at
i sent out to marty and marty takes
[ __ ]
anywhere from three to eight hours
sometimes on these videos right i mean
sometimes it's been longer but
let's just say if i did my good job i
cut it down for him just to hit montages
some overlays some sick [ __ ]
i don't want mario having to place and
cut my voice i would take forever so um
that would take me about ten ten hours
takes marty so each video is roughly 30
hours plus if it's a review like
close-ups
okay so it takes a while these are tv
shows essentially at this point
so
ready we hired cole he came down here
and go hey how do you feel about taking
over my dopaziola videos
so
starting with today after this podcast
i'm going to film with nikita i'm
filming a video
i'm going to give all that footage to
cole it's the first time i've ever
letting somebody take over the whole
thing
but he was here he was sitting down with
me and i'm like yo let's fake edit so
i'm like yo let's watch the store piece
of the story time all right here's all
the raw footage put in my program and i
go yeah look look how much i'm talking
to
dude some story times will be three
hours
talking going yo so what i'm talking
about nikita's one time man i tell 40
minute story and go
we've been rolling this whole time off
[ __ ]
cut cut it out cut it out so it takes a
long time for me to go oh wait this is
not important story [ __ ] i rant even
when it's just one person well it's just
one person here and um
so
i
showed him like this is why i cut that
this is why i cut that you see this part
that's why i kept it see this breath
that's why i cut that breath out you see
why i left that breath in is because i
was close to my eyes and it'd be a weird
cut for me going hey what's up guys
you're gonna be like what so what are
you gonna do hey what's up guys cut and
then this is gone
so i was showing him why i do everything
attention to detail psychotic it's
insane i go so [ __ ] detailed into
every breath every
eyelash every movement that's what takes
me so long because i want it to be
perfect so i'm showing him everything
and he's like yeah i get it
like all right about two hours into
everything showing him like i think you
could take over a whole edit for me
and and while i'm filming i can go so
coming up next ah [ __ ] that hey cole
real quick cut that last part i'm gonna
start over ready go so rubble that's
what i do for mario sometimes
now i can just do it go hey call this
next part overlay that sick b-roll onto
me talking ready go so if you guys want
to check this out this is 38 thc
and i'm trying to show him like how i
would formulate my video so now i'm
gonna hand over the whole edit to cole
and he's so much faster
so i can take him 10 hours and take him
five four he's so much faster than me
it's like marty taking over
remember how many times said we gotta
clone marty i think we might have
[ __ ] found marty's club all right so
here we go
i now have three extra days not editing
what am i gonna do at home is going oh
i'm not editing what like do i have a
life now
no i'm just going to film more so now
i'm going to film way more adventures of
yola
uh videos and i'm buying the pc today i
know i've been saying that for a week
buying the pc today
i'm gonna start streaming on twitch
twice a week i have extra days now like
i can i now have to fill yeah with [ __ ]
let's make more content that's not just
chill like oh i have a free day
[ __ ] it let's make more content so
hiring coal
hiring cole for the podcast he's helping
us out so much
marty yeah i was sitting here typing and
cole's like yo i just did all that milk
clips
oh my god no it's amazing it's amazing
oh it's a [ __ ] well the thing is
marty could do all this marty also has
three kids and a wife
if marty didn't it'd be okay
[ __ ] it work 12 15 hours a day who gives
a [ __ ]
you can't do that when you have a
responsibility to be a family person too
i mean you can't just be like no no
you watch the kids all [ __ ] day
i'm doing like no no
in real life you had to get a babysitter
at this point so you can't just like
april's my babysitter yeah oh yeah we're
married
it can't be that way so
it helps how much yeah we can have coal
just takes and the thing is
maybe one day he gets so good that you
don't even have to edit our videos
anymore and we go
marty
you don't have to edit my domain videos
anymore like oh my god
this is finally happening and then what
happens
maybe we do two videos a week on this i
mean we start knocking out two episodes
a week exactly it's mandatory it's the
only way to keep growing things but what
i love is that we're pulling like from
within
yeah you know the fact that cole's an
actual fan and that he's so
like personally vested in it is
everything yeah and he was very very
chill very cool didn't creep me out
didn't say anything dumb yeah
it's really easy it's easy to [ __ ]
work for us if you just
crush it and you're just on the ball you
smoke weed while you do it man yeah like
the coolest job of all from home
i don't care just give me the [ __ ] yeah
uh-huh and i'll pay you
yeah well let literally like
so cole's moving to l.a that's what
we're trying to get to all right he came
out here while you see here started
looking for apartments we knew it's
gonna work it's gonna work so yeah shout
out to cole for the first member on our
[ __ ] team [ __ ] yeah we we added three
members to our [ __ ] staff basically
for push trees two of them
one one for cole and essentially taking
the dopamillo over too so guys we're
gonna have so much more content and this
is the year of the vlog i'm bringing the
vlogs back all right i'm gonna start the
restrictions are getting lifted
everywhere mass you're not gonna have
mass soon i'm gonna be able to actually
[ __ ] talk to you guys outside again
it's really weird like what's up guys
today we're in [ __ ] qriket park like
[ __ ]
it's not the same so that's where we're
at today guys uh we're stepping [ __ ] up
right everything's moving really good
upgrades yeah [ __ ] yeah camera upgrade
i'm so excited to get back out on my
photography [ __ ] my videography [ __ ]
yeah like it really is this lens is bomb
yeah
um i was chilling with eric kahn the
other night
and his camera set up i always told him
like yo your shit's so clean like what
do you use and he showed me i'm like are
you [ __ ] kidding me that was like a
ten thousand dollar setup it's a fairly
not
expensive setup and his [ __ ] is so clean
because i want to start vlogging more
and i these just don't cut it for me
yeah they're great they're great i need
to be able to hook up a mic i want to be
able to hook up my mic yeah do all the
[ __ ] auto focus auto snap settings like
i need it this one's great too but it's
not as
hefty
i don't know anyway i'm going to get
that set up so i can live stream from
that by the way that camera you can plug
it in and live stream like this one too
that's a [ __ ] game changer so you're
doing twitch yeah it's that quality
exactly
[ __ ] out of here
i'm on youtube live what's up guys now
today
macro oh
[ __ ]
so that's where we're at today guys uh
this episode
we are
how many times gonna come back last year
was about branding right we say it so
much and it works so well yeah yeah and
uh this year is literally about
expanding yeah
delegating to give you more time to go
push forward and do new things first
time in my life yeah i've ever had help
yeah just like great example now you're
out you no jump rope [ __ ] uh be real
[ __ ] and i had omar film me when we do
no jumper as a vlog i'm like yo perfect
i don't have to do this yeah and worry
about all these things like oh my shit's
dying hold up guys hold up
would you say adam's like yeah that's
actually where we [ __ ] the uh porn stuff
oh man i was on no jumper yesterday
where he started talking about something
and he goes like you guys
for the porn stuff he goes yeah actually
that couch right there i made like two
pornos on it and i look back and omar's
like this ratchet man's laying on him
and he sits up like oh
you probably hear it in the video when
it comes out because everybody just
started busting up
and i'm like yo you're you're just
little hair
laying in this he said don't worry it's
been disinfected
yeah
i know it has
that's not the point
i think the point is
that he's just sprawled out first off
why are you sprawled out like
someone's show
chill [ __ ] um but yes i got so
uh i was making fun of him and then he's
like bro i'm about to get in your car
i'm like [ __ ]
i completely forgot about that [ __ ] so i
just stopped talking um
but yeah so that went good oh so uh
tomorrow
tomorrow i'm gonna be in b b reels smoke
box
finally
you guys have been asking for how long
all right how long
be real smoke box tomorrow did no jumper
and then b-roll tomorrow pretty good
week
that was a late
a late horn yeah yeah oh that was a late
one it's been a minute but i gotta i
gotta re-learn the [ __ ] sound banks
here yes yeah so my uh objective is to
smoke it out more than anybody's ever
[ __ ] smoked it out in history i want
to hopefully have them go
i gotta be honest but let's take a
second and then we'll like start filming
again i want it the camera can't focus
yeah i want it to be ridiculous i might
even bring them bong
i have between my legs on my [ __ ]
giant joints but you know
smoke box yeah like i guess smoke box
right
what the [ __ ] i might roll some joints
and give them to them and not let them
know there's a lot of hash in it
right so with their head like
oh yeah by the way there's so much hash
rosin in there keep up
that's what i want like
in my head you know when you're a kid
you play play football like i bet you
one day i'm gonna be like catch over
some guy
crack him run in all the children's
gonna lift me up and i'm gonna be the
cool you know that's what you think like
smoke box i hope everybody's just like
asleep uh-huh yeah i was like no way
it's not gonna happen this was really
[ __ ] smoke i'm just saying like
that'd be the ultimate like going on
johnny carson going yeah johnny carson
left and left the show to me he said i'm
just too funny yeah
he told me to take his chair and his mic
and [ __ ] just
run with it yeah
um
what the [ __ ] happened what are we
talking about oh yeah editing so now we
delegated everything i have a lot more
time marty has
not any more time we're still doing [ __ ]
but
for me on the editing side you guys how
many times you hear me i'm [ __ ]
editing all day today i'm about to be
back in my groove though we were so nice
for about [ __ ] six months there you
know record tuesday have it ready by the
before the weekend like i think we're
doing better now i think we're doing
better now with doing those two episodes
a day i mean remember we did trevor
wallace and right back dr drew that was
great our lives were so much easier yeah
i was talking to adam 22 and he's like
no bro i'll [ __ ] film four episodes
in one day three the next day i'm done
like you're [ __ ]
that's so tight
god i wish i could do that like what
badass
um
so yeah that's what we're doing guys the
catch-up episode okay
wins and losses don't be afraid to talk
about the losses because that might help
somebody else i guarantee you there's a
videographer out there that just put an
air tag in their box because you said it
man i felt like i went against my own
[ __ ] creed with that [ __ ] like that's
something i should have done the most
militant person i've ever seen with you
something i show the [ __ ] dead like
[ __ ] the air squeezers
you're pretty on it man let's just say
that and your knife
yeah i already went i know i got a new
one oh you did okay all right
you know if you're a white man with a
[ __ ] straight billed hat you have a
knife on your head
and it's just a fact as soon as you get
the hat it forms on your head
i'm telling you dude it's true every
dude uh-huh yeah [ __ ] my mine's a safety
thing mine's got the thing the [ __ ]
bust out the windshield the car
yeah yeah the dope but i mean you know
as i started realizing everything that
was in my pelican case 360 was in there
that's a bit i know i [ __ ] i was
going to film some 360 [ __ ] today and
i'm like oh good it was in the [ __ ]
case you should do buy it on the [ __ ]
podcast budget um
yeah i just use it here yeah
who's
that's the beauty about this [ __ ] it's
so [ __ ] nice i know i've
i'm aware of just so many people like
that you know have podcasts or that are
in this kind of business and they have
[ __ ] epic meltdowns over little
things they have meltdowns they get all
pissed off and butt hurt about [ __ ]
anytime anything ever goes wrong you're
just like all right well no don't
[ __ ] trip out i'm always ready to
shoot myself in the head
all right we're gonna it'll be okay
so you can't fix it
let's move on
because that's what i tried to learn
like if you can't fix it why are you
gonna sit there and be mad yeah
yeah it's not that's teamwork that's how
to make uh
that's longevity because yeah we're
gonna we're gonna be fine yeah i was
watching a lot of uh letterman jay leno
conan
watching a lot of i've been watching for
months now [ __ ]
norm mcdonald compilations and then he
[ __ ] passed away and it was it's so
much worse watching now just pisses me
off like are you kidding me
this one yeah you take this one there's
some [ __ ]
and uh just watching him [ __ ] ruin
interviews is my favorite
thing
oh my god because he was on my list to
get he passed away
bob sage was on our list again talking
to his people [ __ ] bob saggy passes
away
i mean both of those people i wanted to
talk to
both of them passed away
that motherfucker's funny and dirty and
vulgar and i love that [ __ ]
um
so i'm watching them and i'm like yo
i think i can do this
i think i can be one of these men right
here like
i always say when i'm 36 i'll really
grow up because that's the age that you
are in the twilight zone mark something
age 36. uh john this age 36 and every
time i watch like 36 seems to be an age
where you have a briefcase
and slick hair
look like talk show guy every time i
mean rosie tried to kill all the
twilight zones from the ones from the
50s trying to do them all over the 60s
and it's hard i'm not like there's like
50 episodes
a season so we're on like season like
four but anyway age 36 seems to be the
number and i always thought like
36 huh
it's gonna be a good year you're growing
at 36. i'm sorry it's good yeah
i'm finally starting to feel
almost grown
35 right yeah
like you're almost
on age
you're getting there
that's what it is man yeah in my 20s i
always felt like i'd like put [ __ ] off
to like like handle that when i'm
[ __ ] worried about that when i'm you
know 35 like i always kind of thought
that too yeah and that's not cool you
shouldn't do that never
never but uh
what the [ __ ] was i talking about we
just started talking about the twilight
zone being 36 years old oh i'm pretty
sure i could be a late night talk show
host yeah yeah i'm pretty sure after i
saw david letterman go uh uh 77 times i
went damn
i'd do that i could do this shut up and
high as [ __ ] yeah i was like but i'm
[ __ ] up maybe i won't smoke so much
before these shows i think there's gonna
be a day where i'm not smoking as much
anymore
but when i smoke i'm going hard
like there's gonna be days where i wake
up
and we're coming to the studio i'm
already imagining all this we're coming
to the studio
that our company that we're with
has for us and they have our [ __ ] ready
to go and we walk in and they're you
don't touch a camera
you walk in and put your [ __ ] up i'm not
all frantic and sweaty and chilly
no mario puts in like an hour and a half
before every episode of setting up it's
crazy
and we're gonna walk in and i feel like
that's gonna be the setting like
all right we just walked in and walked
out cool we made money
during this episode oh my god it's so
crazy coming in here going
we got paid to to come in today it's
like a dream holy [ __ ] um
so that's basically
i [ __ ] lost train of thought again
that's where i was thinking i think i'd
be a late night talk show host
eventually i stopped saying uh 62 times
but i mean of course you've really shown
a lot of versatility with these
different kind of guests and that too
that too but i feel like damn it's so
easy for talk shows to go no no you want
to be here
no you you can get anybody yeah
yeah yo you make all the [ __ ] that's
hard for us
yeah easy if i can just walk in and walk
out i'll watch the behind the scenes of
the kirby enthusiasm seinfeld reunion
episode it's a big sentence i just said
and bro larry david walks in
sees the set built sees all the camera
people like uh
change this don't like this change this
part
and it's done
now as a person on camera you just walk
in yeah and don't have to worry about
production editing lighting they've done
that everything
yeah
how easy my life would be
if i got to walk in here
sit down and start and go hey
all the clips and everything is posted
correct
all the guests are booked all the all
the sponsors the sponsors are ready to
go there's my list okay
next week oh
next week oh i love that guy uh yeah
it's all my world we're getting pretty
close close it's just all that in
between time is still
just on the phone figuring [ __ ] out
locking people in follow it's really 80
following up with people i'm saying if
we didn't have to have the stress of
then again a lot of podcasters don't
have
hhd company two channels the clothing
company like that's like four other
things i do every day besides this [ __ ]
so i think it's like it would be so easy
just to walk in and leave and as i leave
i go
i am done
like can i say these i am done
this is what you signed up for as an
entrepreneur though folks
no i was saying how how amazing when i
saw like jerry seinfeld and then walking
like this looks just like the set this
is great can i get my script
wow
there's no stress in your life yeah
there's no stress oh the
at that level the situation's built
around they're not being any stress yes
because they need the performance from
them yeah i'm just like wow yeah what a
stress-free environment i'm just when i
watched that last night like
you [ __ ] kidding me man you know how
[ __ ] happy idea i could just walk and
go what did you feel like yeah yes
but we're not there
and i don't give a [ __ ] i'm still gonna
do everything else
five other jobs but it's like it's worth
it yeah i love doing it but people can
watch in real time now you go up the
levels of this [ __ ]
we have an editor first time in life
like marty's our editor but i'm the
first editor and if mario took over our
edits oh my god it would taste good
i did two of them when we first met what
was it 25 hour edit on that one i was
like bro i can't this is like a [ __ ]
full-time thing full-time job yeah and
24-hour edit is not like okay all of
tuesday nah [ __ ] we have other
[ __ ] to do it's like four hours a day
six hours that day 10 hours that day 24.
[ __ ] man
i'm falling i'm over here falling how
many times i've done this
and i'm just on fast forward and [ __ ]
lost my place i hate it but now thank
you cole for helping
um so yeah that's what it is guys that's
where we're at it's going to be good um
what a rant talk late night talk show uh
it'll happen uh what a rant also if you
guys really really really want to watch
something awkward just type in david
letterman robert de niro interview oh my
god
what happened
why doesn't robert de niro like david
letterman
having a conversation talk show house he
did this the whole time
well yeah you know didn't even look at
the guy but uh
oh my god i'm i'm
dustin hoffman is with him in the
interview and dustin hoffman dr he asked
does rob de niro somebody goes
you know and dustin hoffman responds for
robert de niro some of the times and it
got so awkward that it was the joke was
so real talkative like it got to the
point of like yo are you in a fight
are you gonna [ __ ] fight him
robert de niro did not look like he
wanted to be around david letterman at
all if you have any time guys it's three
parts i watched all of them
it's insane
it's so awkward it made me think like yo
you know how many should i watch last
night i watched the round table actors i
love watching that [ __ ]
mark scorsese
joe pesci al pacino robert de niro at a
table talking oh my [ __ ] god it was
great what else i watched you know don
rickles
the comedian the old gold
was super funny he's pat i think passed
away
he had a show called dinner with don
he'd sit right here all old as [ __ ] at a
nice restaurant and interview
it with scorsese and robert de niro and
he's sitting there talking [ __ ] and
roberto didn't like don rickles that
much when they first met so they're
talking about it because he was in
casino he was like the right-hand man in
casino don rickles
and just watching them interact with don
rick if you guys don't know who he is
he's one of the funniest
he is what
rick uh uh jeff ross just aspires to be
one day like
roasting the [ __ ] out of people like
that yeah he's just that [ __ ] funny
back when racism was like yo that was
hilarious balls it's also offensive but
it's funny
back when that [ __ ] was like king
i mean he roasts [ __ ] watch him
roast the [ __ ] of richard pryor
oh it's bad anyway don rickles is
sitting there with zach galvanakis and
he's like oh yeah all right guys yo go
watch dinner with don i'm ranting here
but i wish we could play this [ __ ] in
the house like three hours last night
would be the best building react the
videos like have you actually be able to
show what you're watching dude i would
love that don rickles so funny before i
before i stop
one other piece of advice for you guys
if you want to watch anything on tv and
just laugh
go on youtube
and type in
james brown drunk interview
it's one of my favorite things i watch
it periodically
i watch it when i want to just like
i gotta get cooler man
i need to be cool not for real guys but
like whenever i feel like man people
aren't the same anymore it's james brown
live on tv
[ __ ] faced
ladies interviewing and she's like you
tell any instant she's like oh my gosh
she's interviewing about his divorce and
like a domestic dispute and he's just
beating around the bush well not talk
about it
i like love
and he's [ __ ] faced at one part he just
starts singing one of his songs
he should start singing
and then he started then people were
talking about a certain person and he
starts going way up he starts screaming
for the guy
but he's not there yeah it was
i love it sorry guys i know i'm ranting
at this point go watch we've got time go
watch robert de niro david letterman
awkward ass interview with dustin
hoffman
and then go watch james brown drunk
interview it's one of my favorite things
ever uncle john used to watch it a lot
nice it's really it's you should watch
it after it's absurd
and as soon as he talks about jesus
sober
it goes right back to being james brown
my grandpa tom thought he was james
brown that's why i love james brown so
much i grabbed a tom the one i showed
you the
grandpa a lot he he looks like a black
person like he straight up looks like an
old black man from like the 60s
big [ __ ] afro wearing bell bottoms
and the shirts and [ __ ] my grandpa then
he danced his ass off he thought he's
james brown my grandpa would do the
splits
at an old man age dancing
doing the [ __ ] the uh shoe shuffle
that goes all the way across that james
brown would do like my grandpa thought
he was just brown
um
but
growing up my mom all her friends like
your dad's black i didn't know your dad
was black like nah my grandma's just
mexican he's just dark as [ __ ]
and like
okay you know what
i can see what you're talking about okay
wait is my grandpa play there was times
i asked my mom like is grandma black how
come i'm not darker or how come i'm not
black because i thought my grandpa was
black when i was a kid because he had a
[ __ ] afro
you know i'm saying like he looked like
a 70s dude like he just looked like one
of those
bell-bottom guys so i thought like
um every time sorry basically what i'm
trying to say i'm ranting here
is uh james brown's my grandpa all right
that's what i'm trying to say is james
brown's my biological grandfather
my grandfather really thought he was
james brown man at my uncle my cousin
shane's wedding he got drunk
and danced his ass off so hard that it
literally like woke everyone up and
everybody stood up to watch my grandpa
dance
it was pretty intense it's not like he
was really great at dancing he just
that was his [ __ ]
so uh james brown is my biological
relative okay
um
maybe you know what i'm gonna get i'm
gonna give you a picture marty of the
picture why i thought my grandpa was a
black guy when i was a kid and his best
friend mr edwards was the black dude
from the south so i'm like oh wow
i was like a three-year-old like oh my
grandma's black and my best friend was
black so i'm like oh all right
i didn't know am i
i'm pretty light
but i was like that's my grandpa right
so
as a kid i was very confused jesus
christ yeah my best friend was my first
girlfriend was a black girl too
and uh in a mexican town which is odd
yeah yeah you got a lot of black people
in merced at all
and my other best friend justin was a
black kid too
turns out yeah you're not black though
i'm not and my grandpa is a mexican dude
he's spanish but
he really loves james brown that's what
i'm trying to say my grandpa really
loved james brown
okay
that's what we'll get at that could you
imagine little me
am i part black
[Laughter]
nah [ __ ] you're not there there
was a moment when i was probably like i
don't know five well your brother was
black
well before but even before that our
neighbors were black like and uh
like my ba all-time best friend like
all those kids next door and like the
older sister would have like boyfriends
come up and i would see them like
walking up from the bottom of the street
and [ __ ] and they'd be so [ __ ] cool
and they'd have like pics on their hair
and [ __ ] and i remember being like five
trying to get a [ __ ] pick to stay in
my golden locks and [ __ ] my mom's
looking at me like
stop i don't know about this
your hair doesn't work that way
you're it's different yeah yeah because
my next-door neighbors remember i told
you there was like 60 [ __ ] grandkids
and cousins and all of them were from
well mr edwards from the south so he was
real [ __ ] southern i guess this is it
it was real
and he worked for gm so all he did was
like work on cars and my god
you couldn't understand words
but
my whole
wow i really grew up in a a mexican
neighborhood with the only black family
in the whole entire town essentially on
that side
huh [ __ ] epiphany i didn't even think
about that
yeah a little preston and big preston
that's my best friend growing up
i never thought about that wow for
growing up in a mexican town i didn't
have any mexican friends as kids
that's [ __ ] weird weird i didn't it
didn't even click
[Music]
and my other best friends was white
mikey which just dm'd me on the podcast
account
a couple months ago i just saw this face
go where's that face looks i haven't
seen him since we're in 10.
[ __ ] mikey lived next door to me on
second street
and he goes yo what's up man it's mikey
you say you're doing good i'm like mikey
what [ __ ] like who is this like
i need to know is this mikey from 2nd
street and it is
holy [ __ ] seeing people's faces like
that is just so weird like i haven't
seen you i was 10 years old
you watched the show yeah oh so
awesome
um
how [ __ ] i've had a couple comments
like yo this is thomas from her set like
yeah who's this
you're like who is this person
uh remember the kid uh what do you bang
mm-hmm from third grade he was on the
live chat yesterday during the video
damn that song pop up wow i said i
responded to him that's legendary whoa
you're the reason why i know what gangs
are
you just popped up like you bro this is
[ __ ] crazy he's on the show
this is the kid from the story time that
changed my whole
shape and life damn yeah [ __ ] adrian
um
we need we need like a mount rushmore of
storytime characters at some point
that'd be crazy
just just yeah kind of like an ode to
all these people on the wall or some
[ __ ] that'd be sick there's so many
people in my life that shaped me in one
way or another whether they did
something so stupid i went
i cannot be like that guy
there's a lot of those that shaped me
like as a four or five year old like ooh
he's an adult oh that guy's a [ __ ]
idiot i remember being a little kid like
no get that guy away man it turns out
like they were [ __ ] idiot yeah
i'm like i was right
um
but yeah man i thought it was really
[ __ ] wild that uh he was on the live
chat like what the [ __ ]
um rat
city yeah let's do it that's how bad
that one what are we at like 130 now 145
somewhere around there i was trying to
keep it closer yeah ran city sorry guys
this last whole half i said we're gonna
keep it tight that second joint is what
did it i think that's what happened
second joint got me um
anything else you want to add marty
i don't think so man this was just
it's been it's been a [ __ ] roller
coaster but it's an amazing roller
coaster
trying to play catch up right now with
my brain i've been so busy i feel like
that was just like the end of a chapter
we're about to start a whole new kind of
chapter here getting into like going
towards the middle of the year oh adam
22 episode was the our year anniversary
yeah
chris
year anniversary guys and the miller
lite one was the year anniversary so
we haven't had a solo episode yet about
it sorry year anniversary was february
8th
that's about to be real another lightest
up in this [ __ ] oh yeah we might
may or may not have fridge behind marty
we'll see
a lit up a blue
billow
[ __ ] sir yeah we're gonna turn that
whole area into the twitch section i
think i think that's where it needs to
be that's next yeah let's come in here
do our [ __ ] after oh how cool it been
like after the game after the episode
like frankly we'll play grand theft auto
you know you're like yeah you won't play
gta [ __ ] i'm you i'm
[Music]
i don't you
play with his character adam 22 homie
was back there chilling like bam
but then we might just hear
yeah that's true
but it's going to be [ __ ] sick
give me tight
um so yeah guys thank you so much for
being here uh this is the catch-up
episode the wins and losses the ranting
the realization that my grandpa is in
fact james brown
all right
covered a lot of ground covered a lot of
different topics today
um
yeah all right cool
thanks guys for being here this is the
quick catch-up episode well what time is
it marty in real life
uh let's see here almost three
i'm about to go film a [ __ ] video at
four
um this is good this is this is great
catch up it's a nice it's nice talking
to you guys thanks for being here uh
it's been a long episode because i kind
of just
spaced
that second joint is what got me i just
started just [ __ ] man
sorry youtube
for [ __ ] getting demonetized uh
all right you you're good yeah i think i
think i'm good too
we appreciate you we're out here working
we're gonna we're gonna keep leveling up
you can watch this [ __ ] in action
and it won't stop man
thank you oh marty told me that he's
gonna drop some music
we won't get too into it but
this is all hypothetical oh hypothetical
this is all hypothetical
that's the album cover
this is all hypothetical allegedly
that's a song
a legend
i don't know man so i've just stole my
camera yeah it's all plays off of tupac
or biggie and two popular who stole it
yeah i was [ __ ] ready to die yeah
ready to die
dear dear robber
no
they're right
blasphemy yeah get out of here all right
guys thank you so much for being here
how'd you say blasphemy was doing this
next on jesus
oh
i got my invisalign off yesterday real
quick before we go
oh my shit's gone he's back and i let
the lady shave my front tooth before no
jumper before no jump i went is there
any possibility of my tooth cracking i
didn't want to go i have an important
interview after this i don't want to go
yeah no thank you guys for having me on
man
so uh
yeah let her shave my tooth
because it that or i had to do more
invisalign and move this front tooth up
they moved the fronts to move the backs
my teeth were completely straight she
even said these are completely straight
i have to touch your fronts go i know
i'm here for grinding
not here for my teeth my straight ass
teeth i'm lucky [ __ ] and then
they moved them
so she had to shave it to make it even
and as she's doing i'm just sitting
there just trying to space and you know
that song
on all the dog commercials it was in my
head for some reason while i'm looking
up like
oh do a good job [ __ ] oh god do a good
job and then i left
the whole time i was rage driving up at
5 00 am to get my uh i was delirious
rage driving to go try to find my
[ __ ] [ __ ] i had a
system in my head heavy it wouldn't oh
because every single concert have you
ever seen anything in my head it's been
[ __ ] stuck in my head since the
concert play one now just started from
the beginning oh wow they really don't
like the government
holy [ __ ]
i don't know how mtv ever allowed system
of a down on there going [ __ ]
government basically but in a really
poetic way
i think that's how they got away with it
because they were very
anti-anti-commercial
mm-hmm
mm-hmm
i got that they're so [ __ ] good dude
it was such a good show
oh my god
[ __ ]
all right let's move on guys thank you
so much for being here my [ __ ] teeth
are back to normal let's get it going uh
thank you for being here we got new
camera employees help
time to to the merch is going to be back
online
yeah we got the we got all the merch in
the warehouse [ __ ] figured out that
cluster [ __ ] this [ __ ] situation
we'll go for another hour and a half
talking about this [ __ ] right now uh
let's just say
i wish
we could clone our brain and go no work
like this do like
act like i'm going to make fun of you if
you do a bad job because your head i'm
going to
it would really bother you if we did
that act like that yeah act like act
like it's for you
act like it's for you that's what i
started saying act like it's your
business
yeah and make a better decision yeah the
merch has been a [ __ ] nightmare to
try [ __ ] nightmare but it's all good
thank you guys for supporting we have it
it's in hand finally in hand all right
so we will be figuring out that this
week i have three extra days
today i'm filming a video and then
sending off the footage to cole
it's a monumental [ __ ] day oh my
[ __ ] god
it's gonna be crazy i can't wait to go
to the post office like no it's my it's
three literally mailing it to him
overnight yeah he's still in idaho he's
gonna move to la so we're gonna
overnight him the footage he's about to
be sick i'm excited guys thank you so
much for being here rap [ __ ]
city part two um
yeah that's everything uh do me a favor
go to
no we no no we don't have the merch up
just come here
tell a [ __ ] friend tell the friend
yeah before you leave do us a favor it
helps a lot leave a like on the video
just
that's all we need it really helps guys
thank you so much for being here
i'm sure another stretch of guests
i guess are coming right after this
episode so we will see you soon and the
next solo we do is going to be a trial
run
on
how i want to do the live shows
all right i've been have too much to do
that's why i didn't do it on this one
might have the time to plan that
so the next solo episode is going to be
a trial run on how i would like to do
live shows because live shows are coming
before the summer we're going to be on
life's [ __ ] stage before the summer
which is pretty [ __ ] cool um la brea
improv is first so just remember if you
want to see us live
we're going to announce that come to the
[ __ ] show
please also like mushrooms i'm going to
see i got to talk to a lawyer
but i had told marty an idea
police also like being
inebriated i'm not going to spike you
all right this is a willingness thing
let's just leave it at that guys thank
you so much for being here this has been
another episode of the dopes usual
podcast if you're still in the [ __ ]
chat thank you so much thank you for
being here guys leave a like on the
video tell a [ __ ] friend if
you're in the car listen to some spotify
apple or wherever else you listen to
podcasts have a dope ass day
all right all right all right we're back
we're back
it's weird it's like we're gonna [ __ ]
timeout and couldn't talk
i always feel like that like all the
teachers in the room man and then the
solo episode's like oh we have a sub
we can say whatever the [ __ ] we want
yeah that was fun
[Music]
perfect
[Music]